shoulda video a nice submit I wanted to
come to news this morning well consider
the FAFSA vector after holding a defense
counsel with the Prime Minister and the
main secretaries of state involved in
order to establish what our response
should be after this horrific attack
where an individual's yeah defend up to
you got behind the wheel when Lori and
use it to kill people do why did that
happen in nice because it's a well-known
city known throughout the world and one
of the most beautiful it is over you in
the world and why did it take place on
bastille days well because I'm Bastille
they were celebrating freedom lafawn so
his aim was to me strike France
undecided to I think the problem is for
me this terrorist attack is it with the
various politicians the size of state
minister in charge of Social Affairs
hard work or called yoga Jesus you
really wanted thirsty for mais duel
favor to get organized in order to well
yes you will detect the bottom of the
city and ensure its full detection with
uvalde completion in case should there
be any associates well whatever because
you're ready to take action means we're
able to counter any such a threat on the
population but we also wanted to express
our sympathy to the victims mom or their
families ghettoville and as I speak yes
son song not 80 people 84 young people
have lost their lives and about 50
you're putting people are in a critical
state Bobby City gimme yo in hospital
difference a long those victims are many
French citizens but also a lotta for the
boutique foreign yeah citizens from
various continues offal and there are a
lot of children among the victims young
children
what one has come to the fireworks dr. G
with their families abinell to celebrate
would you share joy I see you [ __ ]
[ __ ] cool we're struck will
supplement sethi sphere the crew and the
victims of this attack where he put that
without me one man and possibly agree no
usable view she wanted to listen english
this cruel attack you on our citizens to
this image FYI habla there are also a
lot of injured people acted who still
have in mind sure they horrific scenes
scored about dodge yesterday evening and
they're still suffering mmm physically
and mentally comedies fees and there are
people who didn't suffer any physical
harm but who will throughout their lives
what city badge be yo ho traumatized
you're after witnessing bothers you
those horrible local mode Saints green a
lot of them told me yo give you that
they couldn't remember remember any of
what happened last night go did she do
but that the only thing they could
remember where those oh well broken
bodies on the floor don't you on the
ground there's you before their eyes and
that's why we all need to share these
emotion this difficult time with victims
with their families a sympathy to them
you know gazmin grant good with a
vampeer in Fresno go once again what are
they dominated for busy the courage of
the security forces Christopher doctor
fees precept Oh Toki did a security
forces her dad done their utmost to make
this my works is safe as possible for
everyone Sienese as they had done during
the euro is an easy in this occasion
recently
security forces geauga din to neutralize
the perpetrator secrecy and I still
remember them good seeing this young
policeman take action in order to a big
kill knows the perpetrator oxycontin put
an end to the killings is deeply no
organ security forces are fully
committed to this fight you see there
anymore they have been the mall is a
tore down the jockey to me gasps Lizzy
in the past few months of course after
the attacks in the voluntary son
Sundanese said we see for and I'd like
to pay tribute in the form to those for
sissies because they're Jordana our
pride of France I'm talking about the
police there's not an early the
intelligence services those who carry
out the inquiries those who know
identify the victims septic pump you I
don't recall why you just called you now
the firefighters you have done with a
kind extraordinary vehicle and what is
the calm one attended to all the
supporting good have you people involved
the vacant when you see people taking
them to hospital I'm stepping in where
his victims we're also um don't look
different to other places not just
hospitals where there had to be
supported I visited myself limits
hospital here monkey bar oh we're so
he's plenty poor people what Ashton
could do celebrities were not on duty
last night but he still came into the
street the victims and to save lives not
everybody cuz we saved of course yes
unfortunately but I'd like to be helmets
to the staff of these hospitals she
showed extraordinary commitment and of
course mortgages we've also noticeable a
scene howdy volunteer organizations of
energy d helped good one throughout like
this tragedy throughout this terrible
event this terrorist attack which is one
more
terrorist attack after a whole series of
attacks in the phone is that will loom
this fire and in me will be a long one
you recording me because we're faced
with an enemy but we will still strike
here only Liberty comes follow it's all
countries I don't pupils where freedom
potential value do folks and in this
context we need to rely on our she
foresees our agencies and the commitment
of the whole country he did this is your
in the past few months along with the
Prime Minister have taken the necessary
decisions to increase the god don't be a
number of me workers were working for
these alien sis and whose number has
unfortunately been reduced in the past
few years we're remaining vigilant and
we're continuing to their full support
the French people the moment was we can
with what we have to be strong it's been
the whole world is looking is they're
expressing their solidarity to France
all their hands being all the fix you're
expressing solidarity through the group
ah the more the bonds the noon they're
supporting from a before what the
capability show me the whole world knows
however that we are going to disappoint
a strong country able to overcome uofl
whatever is thrown at us and they have
happiness morning anomalies avoid
sinking nice too but i think we showing
a great example to the rest of the
workers way serviceability show the
publication the two lay together ness do
my job if you stick to the commitment
that I DePalma be sorry Arjun Saxena I
suppose Anjali small got inside your
head pulled a delay but when it comes to
defeat you have the right response on
your mythical challenges with your new
sister that see we have to face with
always your necessary me alone this
unity visible because he cohesion that I
could have calling for today
here in Nice true so that France come
out stronger than those we filmed Mullen
West farm horse who's even on inside
that we can defeat them because we all
work together